J'ai jamais très bien compris les gens, le monde qui m'entoure. Bon, c'est l'occasion d'essayer. Je suis Guillaume Hachez.
Vous écoutez Septante Minutes Avec.
Mais bonjour, il y a des épisodes guillerets et folichons où je rigole avec mes invités.
Et puis il y en a d'autres où on couvre des sujets plus sérieux. C'est le cas aujourd'hui puisque mon invité et moi avons discuté des stratégies médiatiques de groupes extrémistes.
La ligne éditoriale de Septante Minutes Avec, c'est que j'essaye de m'attaquer aux thèmes dont nous sommes tous et toutes plus ou moins conscients, mais qu'on a rarement pris le temps d'approfondir.
C'est évident que ces dix dernières années, la Belgique et la France ont été infectées par le fléau qu'est le djihadisme.
On a tous et toutes entendu parler de ces vidéos de décapitation, de la radicalisation sur Internet de jeunes Français et Belges issus de l'immigration.
Mais il me semble que ça reste encore assez flou et abstrait pour beaucoup de gens. Raison pour laquelle j'ai choisi de passer Septante Minutes Avec Laurence Bindner, spécialiste de la question.
C'est parti. J'ai le plaisir d'être aujourd'hui avec Laurence Bindner. Bonjour Laurence.
Bonjour Guillaume.
Laurence, vous êtes experte en ce qui concerne la dissémination des contenus djihadistes en ligne, en propagande et rhétorique djihadistes.
Vous étudiez également le financement et la quantification des activités extrémistes. Vous êtes cofondatrice du JOS Project et vous êtes membre du Counter Terrorism Committee Executive
Directorate Global Research Network au sein du Conseil de sécurité des Nations unies.
C'est très long, un très long titre. Alors avant de se lancer, on va pouvoir explorer de nombreux sujets ensemble en ce qui concerne donc
les stratégies médiatiques des différents groupes extrémistes, notamment djihadistes, et leurs objectifs et toute une série de choses ensemble.
Mais avant de se lancer là-dedans, je pense qu'on a besoin d'un petit moment de recontextualisation.
Qu'est-ce que c'est que le JOS Project et qu'est-ce que c'est que ce CTED, le conseil dont vous faites partie ?
Est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer un petit peu tout ça ?
Alors, je suis cofondatrice de JOS Project. Et JOS Project, c'est une plateforme d'analyse de la propagande extrémiste violente en ligne.
Alors cette propagande, on l'analyse à la fois d'un point de vue dynamique et d'un point de vue plus rhétorique, narratif.
Alors qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ? On l'analyse d'abord d'un point de vue dynamique, c'est-à-dire qu'on regarde d'où est-ce que cette propagande émerge, comment est-ce qu'elle rebondit de plateforme en plateforme, comment est-ce qu'elle
garde sa résilience,
et comment est-ce qu'elle peut contourner l'intervention des différentes plateformes.
Ça, c'est une première chose. Mais dans un second temps, on regarde également qu'est-ce que cette propagande nous dit d'un point de vue discursif
et la manière dont elle le dit, c'est-à-dire qu'est-ce qu'elle raconte dans le fond, quel est le message et quels sont les supports qui véhiculent ce message.
Est-ce que c'est plutôt des audios, des vidéos, du texte, des posters, des documents, etc.
Et ça, évidemment, ça nous éclaire sur les groupes eux-mêmes et sur les messages qui sont susceptibles de mobiliser leur audience.
Et alors, le Global Research Network, c'est
Oui
une sorte de réseau global, en fait, comme son nom l'indique, de personnes qui sont spécialisées sur ce type de thématique à travers le monde.
Et on discute
des contenus extrémistes violents, de la manière dont ils se diffusent, de ce qu'ils racontent également et de la manière dont les États peuvent mieux se défendre et lutter contre ces éléments qui,
à la fois lutter contre, mais tout en préservant une liberté d'expression et tout en gardant un équilibre entre
liberté d'expression, mais quand même une certaine sécurité en ligne pour les internautes.
Et donc qu'est-ce qui vous a amenée à vous pencher sur la stratégie médiatique des groupes extrémistes ? Qu'est-ce qui fait que c'est un sujet qui vous a intéressée ?
Parce qu'à la base, vous êtes diplômée d'école de commerce.
Oui, oui, tout à fait. En fait, je suis diplômée d'école de commerce, mais à titre personnel, je m'intéresse depuis longtemps aux thématiques de radicalisation, aux thématiques de
fanatisme, de violence de groupe, de violence collective.
Et de fil en aiguille, j'ai décidé d'orienter ma carrière vers ce type d'analyse, en mettant un peu à profit ce que j'ai appris dans le conseil dans une précédente vie, au service de cet engagement-là.
OK. Et donc, vous disiez déjà à titre personnel, ça vous intéressait. Donc qu'est-ce qui a allumé cette flamme chez vous ?
Qu'est-ce qui fait que ça
C'est une simple appétence intellectuelle pour
OK
l'idée de comprendre en fait ce qui fait qu'un groupe humain
peut commettre des exactions de masse, sous couvert, enfin en tout cas sous couvert d'une idéologie et comment est-ce qu'ils peuvent être embrigadés et perdre quelque part le sens des valeurs, du bien et du mal.
Je comprends. Je comprends. Et à quel moment est-ce que ça a commencé, cet intérêt ?
Depuis longtemps. Depuis longtemps. Je suis intéressée par ces thématiques depuis longtemps. Et puis, en 2012, en France, on a eu Mohamed Merah.
En 2015, on a eu les attentats de janvier et de novembre. Et c'est à partir de ce moment-là que j'ai décidé d'essayer de mettre à profit
Ouais. Cet intérêt.
Voilà, cet intérêt à titre professionnel.
OK. Donc pour, voilà, se replonger donc au cœur du sujet qu'on va explorer ensemble, donc les stratégies médiatiques de ces groupes extrémistes.
Y a évidemment plusieurs niveaux. Y a les communications qui se font, entre guillemets, pour le grand public, sur les réseaux classiques que sont Facebook, Twitter, etc.
Et puis y a les communications qui se font, disons, pour les initiés dans l'Internet un peu plus sombre, dans les groupes privés, voilà, sur Telegram, sur ce qu'on appelle le Dark Web, etc.
À l'échelle des réseaux dont on parle, donc par exemple Twitter, Facebook et Telegram, quelle est la place que ces contenus terroristes occupent ?
Est-ce que c'est quelque chose qu'on va trouver vraiment à toute petite échelle, qui va se faire très discret ?
Ou bien est-ce que, au contraire, ces gens essaient d'occuper un maximum de place et un maximum de visibilité ?
Alors, c'est une question qui est intéressante et vaste et je pense que ça mérite de revenir, de faire un petit flashback sur un certain nombre de faits
pour que les auditeurs aient une meilleure idée de la façon dont ça a évolué, notamment ces dernières années.
D'abord, pour revenir à la question de départ, je crois qu'il faut pour ces groupes souligner l'importance de la maîtrise de la communication.
Les groupes terroristes, extrémistes violents, les groupes insurrectionnels, ils sont dans le combat du faible contre le fort.
Ils sont dans une lutte asymétrique, contre un adversaire qui est plus puissant.
Et en cela, la maîtrise des canaux de communication, pour eux, la maîtrise du discours, ça va être crucial dans cette lutte asymétrique.
Et alors, pour appréhender la place actuelle des contenus extrémistes violents sur les réseaux sociaux,
je crois qu'il faut donc faire un petit flashback et comprendre ce qu'a constitué le bouleversement d'Internet initial en premier lieu et ensuite ce qu'a constitué l'importance du web participatif, du Web deux point zéro,
et comment est-ce qu'on est arrivé jusqu'à la situation actuelle.
Alors, ce qu'il faut comprendre, c'est que les groupes terroristes ont immédiatement perçu l'intérêt que pouvait représenter Internet pour eux en termes de diffusion du message.
Ça leur a immédiatement permis de changer de braquet en termes d'échelle.
La diffusion par Internet, c'était peu coûteux, c'était instantané, ça leur permettait de toucher une audience au niveau international.
Et surtout, en fait, Internet leur a permis de s'affranchir des filtres éditoriaux. Ça leur a permis
C'est ça. Donc quand Ben Laden envoyait ses VHS à Al Jazeera et compagnie, Al Jazeera pouvait décider d'éditer en partie le contenu, de ne pas montrer la totalité du contenu.
Maintenant, les groupes tels que Al-Qaïda ou l'État islamique peuvent atteindre un public général, mais presque directement ou, oui, directement, sans aucun filtre.
Exactement. En fait,
tout à fait. Ben Laden, à l'époque, Ben Laden ou des groupes type Al-Qaïda, les groupes djihadistes, leur propagande à l'époque, ça pouvait être des cassettes VHS, ça pouvait être des écrits, des journaux, etc.
qui étaient un peu transmis sous le manteau, en contrebande quelque part. C'était assez risqué. Mais surtout, le fait que Ben Laden doive passer par Al Jazeera, par CNN, etc.
pour ses grands messages, pour ses grandes interviews, le rendait dépendant du filtre éditorial de ces médias.
Alors que là, Internet lui permet de maîtriser la chaîne de communication depuis la production du message jusqu'à sa diffusion, en passant par l'édition de ses contenus.
Donc la maîtrise de la chaîne de communication sans intermédiaire. Et donc ça, c'est évidemment révolutionnaire, révolutionnaire pour eux.
Bon, et en plus de ça, évidemment, la portée d'Internet est vraiment considérable par rapport à la portée d'une cassette VHS ou de journaux qui pouvaient être envoyés d'Afghanistan ailleurs dans le monde, en Europe, etc.
Donc voilà, on change de dimension en termes de volume, en termes de sécurité et en termes de maîtrise de cette communication.
Donc ça, ça a été vraiment un moment important, un moment clé dans cette maîtrise du message.
Et donc on voit les premiers sites djihadistes qui apparaissent à la fin des années quatre-vingt-dix, premiers sites d'Al-Qaïda qui apparaissent autour de l'an 2000.
Et après le onze septembre 2001, les autorités américaines vont cibler ces sites. Et c'est à partir de ce moment-là que va apparaître, je pense qu'on en reparlera sans doute plus tard, mais une sorte d'embryon de guérilla en ligne
avec une espèce de volonté de ces groupes de rester en ligne, de maintenir leur présence.
Alors, ils le faisaient à l'époque en dupliquant les contenus, eux-mêmes ou par des sympathisants, en créant des sites miroirs, et cetera.
Ce qui leur permettait de pouvoir être résilients et de garder une empreinte numérique.
Et donc là, on est à peu près au milieu des années 2000
et c'est à partir de ce moment-là qu'il va y avoir un autre game changer qui va être le Web 2.0, donc avec des interfaces plus simples, mais surtout avec une communication qui est
facilitée, qui est encore plus horizontalisée entre
l'émetteur du message et le récipiendaire du message.
Donc, on a les premiers forums qui étaient d'abord en arabe, puis ensuite en anglais, puis en français, en langue vernaculaire.
Et, au-delà des groupes, c'est chacun, chaque sympathisant, chaque militant qui peut avoir un accès, qui peut avoir une communication beaucoup plus directe, beaucoup plus horizontale avec son audience cible.
Oui, donc, donc vraiment,
il s'agit là d'un outil clé, un outil central dans la stratégie de ces groupes, pour, voilà, toucher un public plus large et potentiellement,
je sais pas, ben j'imagine, en fait, je vais vous poser la question, potentiellement donc recruter par ce biais de nouveaux membres, donc à travers le monde.
Est-ce que c'est juste de dire ça ?
Absolument. Absolument. Alors, y a
différents types de fonctions à Internet. Mais d'abord, pour répondre à votre question initiale,
parce que là, on en est au milieu des années 2000, je pense que c'est intéressant d'arriver jusqu'à aujourd'hui et de comprendre un petit peu quelle est la dialectique entre les réseaux sociaux
Tout à fait
qu'on publie type Facebook, Twitter et puis quelque chose qui est plus dark. Donc en fait, on est au milieu des années 2000, avec une
horizontalisation de la communication et qui va de pair, en fait, qui s'opère de manière concomitante avec la décentralisation d'Al-Qaïda.
Al-Qaïda passe d'une organisation très centralisée, très pyramidale au début des années 2000 à une
Centralisée donc autour de la figure du leader, de
Autour de la figure du leader, avec un command and control vraiment, au départ, c'était vraiment l'Afghanistan, et cetera.
Et puis, au fur et à mesure des années et puis des coups qui sont reçus de la part du contre-terrorisme américain, il y a une décentralisation d'Al-Qaïda avec la création de filiales de manière successive.
Donc il y a Al-Qaïda en Irak, les Shabab en Somalie, AQMI, AQPA, tout ça entre 2004 et 2009, 2010. Ensuite, il y en a une autre au Mali, et cetera.
Et donc cette décentralisation est concomitante avec l'horizontalisation de la communication. Il y a une autre forme également de décentralisation d'Al-Qaïda, c'est que, à partir du milieu des années 2000, on va avoir une
nouvelle forme de paradigme de la part de ce groupe qui est le paradigme du djihad sans leader.
C'est-à-dire que,
jusqu'à présent, c'était une organisation pyramidale, organisée, centralisée, mais, suite notamment à un écrit d'Abu Musab al-Suri, qui est un théoricien proche de Ben Laden, on va avoir une
recommandation de la part d'Al-Qaïda central d'autonomisation des cellules.
C'est-à-dire qu'il faut plus avoir une organisation tellement hiérarchisée, pyramidale, parce que sinon,
on se prend trop de répercussions du contre-terrorisme, mais en fait, on va fonctionner davantage de manière réticulaire, rhizome, de manière réticulaire, avec des petites cellules décentralisées.
Et ça, ça arrive de manière concomitante avec ce Web participatif 2.0. Vous voyez, avec une espèce de décentralisation et d'autonomisation des cellules.
Voilà. Donc ça, c'est au milieu des années 2000. Et c'est également au milieu des années 2000 qu'apparaissent les premiers réseaux sociaux.
Mmh-mmh. Oui, c'est ça. Donc c'est finalement assez logique puisque donc le Web 2.0 arrive, ouais, 2004, 2006, pour Facebook et Twitter respectivement.
Et donc ces groupes-là, finalement, cette décentralisation dont on vous parlait, finalement, logique dans l'histoire d'Internet, en fait.
Oui, tout à fait. Alors sauf que, au milieu des années 2000, les groupes djihadistes, au départ, étaient assez réticents à l'utilisation de Facebook, de YouTube, et cetera,
parce qu'ils étaient hébergés, ces sites étaient, ces plateformes étaient hébergées aux États-Unis et qu'ils craignaient d'être infiltrés par le renseignement américain.
Donc, ils ont été très frileux quant à l'utilisation de ces plateformes. Et ce n'est qu'au début des années 2010, avec
l'immigration massive de jeunes Européens, de jeunes Maghrébins, en Syrie et en Irak, et eux qui étaient rompus à l'usage de ces réseaux-là, que, en quelque sorte, les groupes sont rattrapés par la modernité
Mh.
et sont plus ou moins contraints
d'avoir des membres qui utilisent ces plateformes. Mais force est de constater qu'ils en ont bien tiré leur épingle du jeu et qu'ils ont su justement utiliser cet usage,
pour booster un certain nombre de choses.
Et donc, oui, ben donc cet usage-là de ces nouvelles plateformes, concrètement, à quoi est-ce que ça ressemble ?
Si on imagine, si on visualise le contenu que ces membres de ces groupes djihadistes vont alors faire apparaître sur ces réseaux ?
À quoi est-ce qu'on fait face ?
Alors, à quoi est-ce qu'on fait face ? On fait face à un certain nombre de choses. On fait face d'abord à...
En fait, pourquoi les groupes djihadistes utilisent Internet, utilisent les réseaux sociaux ?
Ils utilisent Internet et les réseaux sociaux pour un certain nombre de choses. Ils les utilisent pour faire passer leur message, leurs grandes lignes stratégiques, leurs grandes lignes idéologiques.
Ils les utilisent également comme une sorte de plateforme opérationnelle. Je reviendrai là-dessus.
Et ils les utilisent également pour le recrutement, pour communiquer avec des recrues potentielles.
Alors, pour ce qui est des grandes lignes directrices, c'est à travers cette propagande que l'on peut comprendre ce que les groupes djihadistes veulent faire.
Il faut bien voir qu'en fait, tout ce qu'ils veulent faire, ils l'annoncent et ils annoncent ce qu'ils vont faire et ils font ce qu'ils ont annoncé.
Donc, si on veut comprendre leurs grandes lignes directrices, leur stratégie, il faut lire leur propagande parce que tout est indiqué dedans de manière assez claire.
Je crois qu'on peut donner plusieurs exemples. En 2004, 2005, ce sont les années où sont sortis deux ouvrages importants.
Par exemple, l'ouvrage auquel je faisais référence tout à l'heure de Abu Musab al-Suri,
Appel à la résistance islamique globale et un autre ouvrage qui est attribué à un autre djihadiste, pas de manière sûre, qui s'intitule La gestion de la barbarie.
Et ce sont ces deux ouvrages qui ont permis
d'annoncer en fait le nouveau paradigme de la décentralisation, du djihad sans leader, de la façon dont il fallait renverser les régimes en place, etc., etc.
Je rentre pas dans le détail de ces deux ouvrages, mais c'est juste pour vous donner une illustration de l'annonce de la stratégie par la propagande.
Et beaucoup plus récemment, en 2014, c'est lors d'un discours d'un des anciens porte-parole de l'État islamique, Abu Musab
Abu Mohammed al-Adnani, que le groupe a incité ses sympathisants qui ne pouvaient plus émigrer en terre de Sham, de Syrie et en Irak,
parce qu'ils étaient entravés dans leur émigration, de mener un djihad à la maison, entre guillemets, dans leur pays d'origine, parce qu'ils pouvaient plus accéder en terre de djihad.
Donc, vous voyez, à nouveau, en fait,
ils annoncent ce qu'ils font et ils font ce qu'ils ont annoncé. Donc c'est évidemment crucial de pouvoir avoir un accès à cette propagande pour comprendre en fait les grandes lignes de leur stratégie.
Et vous avez évoqué un concept qui m'intéresse beaucoup. Vous avez parlé du djihad sans leader.
À quelle époque est-ce que ce concept est apparu et qu'est-ce que ça signifie exactement, cet intérêt pour ce nouveau paradigme ?
En fait, donc c'est apparu au milieu des années 2000, notamment dans l'ouvrage de Abu Musab al-Suri.
Et l'idée de cet ouvrage, c'était de se dire voilà, avec le 11 septembre, Al-Qaïda, en quelque sorte, a été trop ambitieux, a eu les yeux plus gros que le ventre et en fait, le retour de bâton est trop fort.
On est une organisation qui est trop centralisée, qui est en fait atteignable par les Américains, par l'armée américaine, etc.
Mais l'idée, en fait, ce serait de fonctionner de manière beaucoup plus décentralisée, et avec des cellules autonomes qui se fondent en fait plus dans les populations, qui
qui participeraient à des attentats, des petits attentats, ce qu'on a appelé la stratégie des mille entailles.
Donc non pas des gros attentats avec un certain hubris, comme ce fut pour le 11 septembre, mais plutôt des petits attentats qui vont polariser la société et qui vont en fait pousser les populations à
à montrer du doigt les populations musulmanes, à les radicaliser.
Et ces mêmes populations musulmanes,
dans une sorte de cercle vicieux de radicalisation réciproque, pourraient elles-mêmes être davantage radicalisées, poussées dans leurs retranchements et rejoindre des groupes plus extrémistes.
Donc c'est vraiment dans une sorte d'optique de polarisation réciproque et de saigner en fait les sociétés par l'intérieur, par des petites actions, mais nombreuses et
pas forcément organisées ou avec des armes complexes, etc., mais des petites actions,
au sein des sociétés, des sociétés occidentales.
Et votre question est intéressante parce que ça rappelle évidemment un ouvrage de Louise Bim,
qui est à l'ultra-droite, qui parle également de ce phénomène de djihad sans leader et de décentralisation des cellules.
Donc, on voit, alors, je ne sais pas si les uns ont lu les autres, mais on voit qu'il y a une sorte de résonance entre les deux mouvances et les deux types de recommandations en termes de mode opératoire.
Mh. Mh. Oui, puisque vous avez également travaillé donc sur les groupes d'ultra-droite, donc même si c'est moins votre focal.
Et donc voilà, vous dites qu'il y a donc des parallèles, il y a presque des formes d'admiration. Est-ce que c'est juste de dire ça entre les groupes d'ultra-droite envers donc les groupes djihadistes ?
Alors,
oui, il peut y avoir des formes d'admiration. Mais je crois que en fait, ce qui est très intéressant,
c'est qu'il y a une sorte de,
y a des-- Bah d'abord, y a des nombreuses similitudes,
dans les modes opératoires en ligne, mais il y a également des résonances dans les messages entre la propagande islamiste radicale et la propagande d'ultra-droite.
En fait, les uns se positionnent a priori comme, comment dire, l'antidote des autres, mais il se trouve que, par un phénomène intéressant, l'un et l'autre se nourrissent mutuellement.
Mh.
En fait, une des différences importantes entre les groupes djihadistes et d'ultra-droite, c'est que les groupes djihadistes, eux, sont structurés en grands groupes.
Vous avez Al-Qaïda, vous avez l'État islamique, vous avez Hayat Tahrir al-Sham, vous avez des grands groupes et, en ligne, ça se structure également comme ça, autour de ces grands groupes.
Pour ce qui est de l'ultra-droite, y a pas vraiment de grands groupes qui structurent cette mouvance. C'est beaucoup plus atomisé, c'est beaucoup plus fragmenté, c'est plus
émietté et ça se retrouve également en ligne.
Et, en ligne, on a vraiment toute une kyrielle de petites fondations médiatiques, de petits groupes qui opèrent, qui sont dans différents sous-segments de l'ultra-droite.
Alors ça peut être les néonazis, ça peut être des suprémacistes, ça peut être des survivalistes, des écofascistes, des wotanistes, etc.
Des odinistes, pardon. Et voilà. Et tout ce monde-là est très très fragmenté. Pour ce qui est de l'admiration dont on parlait il y a quelques-
Mh.
Il y a quelques minutes, je crois que y a effectivement une certaine... Alors déjà, y a des résonances dans les visions du monde.
On, y a une résonance, ils partagent en fait un certain nombre de réalités, de visions du monde, ces différentes mouvances.
Ils partagent, en termes de grief, ils partagent l'idée du complexe obsidional, d'être menacé par un out group.
Ils partagent l'idée d'idéaliser le passé, d'avoir un passé glorieux, les grands temps de l'islam d'un côté, ou alors les grands temps de l'Europe blanche de l'autre côté.
Ils partagent un certain antisémitisme, tant à l'ultra-droite que dans la mouvance djihadiste. Ils partagent également une vision de la femme qui est très, très-
Misogynie.
Éfféminée.
Mh. Mh.
Une image de, une idée de la génération suivante, de la préparation du combat par la génération suivante, des enfants qui sont les combattants de demain.
Mh.
Donc une vision, si vous voulez, une vision sociétale à long terme, etc. La critique des déviances, déviances entre guillemets, de la société occidentale, etc., etc.
Et donc les deux mouvances se situent vraiment dans un état d'esprit où ils sont menacés de manière existentielle.
Et donc l'idée pour eux, c'est de mobiliser
les sympathisants, pour passer de ce qu'ils estiment être dans un état défensif à l'offensif, et ce qui justifie évidemment tous les moyens offensifs pour se défendre par rapport à cette menace existentielle.
Et là où il y a l'admiration qui apparaît, c'est que, récemment, les djihadistes ont commis un certain nombre d'attentats, notamment des attentats kamikazes.
Et, en cela, y a un certain nombre de militants d'ultra-droite qui admirent ce jusqu'au-boutisme et le fait-
Mh.
D'être-
De pouvoir se sacrifier pour sa cause quoi.
Exactement, de pouvoir aller jusqu'à la mort pour sa cause.
Mh.
Et donc ça, ça apparaît effectivement en ligne avec une sorte de partage dans les sphères d'ultra-droite, d'une imagerie à la gloire de certains djihadistes.
Et on a même vu une volonté, dans divers événements qui se sont produits les dernières années, de même de coopération dans une optique accélérationniste.
C'est-à-dire qu'on a
un groupe aux États-Unis,
suprémacistes blancs qui voulaient passer par Al-Qaïda pour attaquer une unité militaire, pour
susciter des représailles et initier une sorte de guerre raciale dans une optique accélérationniste,
pour accélérer en quelque sorte le chaos de la société et pouvoir rebâtir une société plus pure sur des bases différentes une fois que la société actuelle sera détruite.
Donc voilà. Donc en fait, cette admiration et cette volonté de coopération peut même parfois aller assez loin.
Mh. Oui. Et donc on, voilà, on explore donc ces différents groupes que sont donc, voilà, là on parle, on a parlé pendant l'instant donc de l'ultra-droite.
On a évoqué Al-Qaïda, on a évoqué l'État islamique. Quelles sont alors les différences entre les stratégies médiatiques, voilà, de ces différents groupes, de Al-Qaïda, de l'État islamique ?
Est-ce que c'est juste dire que Al-Qaïda, aujourd'hui, est plutôt au second plan, qu'on l'a un peu oublié en comparaison avec l'État islamique, Daesh, dont on parle, voilà, très régulièrement, notamment
sur les médias, disons de droite, voilà, aux États-Unis, en Europe.
Est-ce que c'est juste de dire ça, qu'Al-Qaïda est finalement passé au second plan ?
Bah pas tout à fait. En fait, ce qui s'est produit, c'est que l'État islamique, quand le groupe a mis en place son califat, son proto-État,
l'idée pour lui, c'était de devenir en quelque sorte la marque leader sur le marché du djihad, sur le marché cognitif du djihad, et de réussir son entreprise califale.
Et pour réussir son entreprise califale, il devait peupler ce califat. Et donc, pour ces deux objectifs, il a mis en place une propagande, une machinerie de propagande, de production de masse et de consommation de masse.
Et ça a été vraiment quelque chose de très différent par rapport à Al-Qaïda. Mais si vous voulez, en fait, il y a un certain nombre de caractéristiques
d'Al-Qaïda et de l'État islamique qui vont s'incarner dans leur stratégie média et qui vont s'exprimer par leur stratégie numérique.
Al-Qaïda, en termes de stratégie, Al-Qaïda, ce que le groupe souhaite, c'est d'instaurer effectivement un califat, mais plutôt à moyen terme et en conquérant les cœurs et les esprits.
L'État islamique, lui, ce qu'il a voulu, c'est instaurer un califat à très court terme et par la force.
Mh.
Al-Qaïda, en termes idéologiques, il n'y avait pas de ciblage systématique des non-sunnites et des non-musulmans.
L'État islamique, de son côté, a excommunié de manière très systématique les non-musulmans, les non-sunnites et même au sein des sunnites, ceux qui ne suivaient pas son dogme.
C'est ça, oui. Soit on est radical, soit on suit la vision très extrême, c'est le cas de le dire, de l'État islamique, soit on est finalement son ennemi.
Tout à fait. Et le troisième, la troisième grande différence, donc je schématise un petit peu, mais en gros, c'est, il y a ces trois différences-là.
La troisième grande différence, c'est que Al-Qaïda a un positionnement qui est unificateur, qui essaye d'être unificateur, mais élitiste.
Alors que l'État islamique, lui, ce qu'il voulait, c'était peupler son califat, recruter, faire venir des personnes en Syrie, en Irak, et donc il avait une stratégie de recrutement très large.
Donc d'un côté, on est sur Al-Qaïda dans un positionnement qui est très politisé, très élitiste. Et de l'autre côté, côté État islamique, on est dans un positionnement, un recrutement large, tous azimuts.
Et donc tout ça, ça va s'incarner dans la stratégie numérique des deux groupes. Du côté d'Al-Qaïda, on est sur des formats qui sont plus longs, plus cérébraux.
Il n'y a pas beaucoup d'effets spéciaux. Alors que côté État islamique, on est sur des formats plus courts, très, très variés, avec des effets spéciaux, animés de manière différente.
Ça, c'est en termes de format. En termes de dissémination, chez Al-Qaïda, on est davantage toujours sur plutôt du moyen, long terme.
Donc, on est plus dans une recherche de plateformes qui vont être stables, qui auront une certaine longévité. Alors que pour l'État islamique, il y a une recherche plus impatiente de viralité, de
de plateformes très très grand public type Facebook, Twitter, etc.
Oui, oui.
Et chez Al-Qaïda, on a des contenus qui sont plutôt déclinés par région et de manière assez cérébrale.
Alors que l'État islamique va jouer beaucoup plus sur l'émotionnel-
Mh.
Et beaucoup plus sur l'ultra-violence. L'ultra-violence est quasiment proscrite de la propagande d'Al-Qaïda.
Elle l'est pas dans la propagande de l'État islamique. Et ça a été vraiment un,
un des game changers et un des éléments qui ont fait que la propagande de l'État islamique, quelque part, a été extrêmement médiatisée et a fonctionné.
On va, on peut explorer toutes ces questions, mais simplement, quand on vous écoute et que vous décrivez donc l'État islamique comme, voilà, adhérant à une forme d'ultra-violence.
Et alors que Al-Qaïda,
si je reprends vos termes, cherche plutôt à conquérir les cœurs et les esprits de manière plus,
voilà, plus soft, si je comprends bien ce que vous dites, ça ne rejoint pas vraiment l'image de l'inconscient collectif qu'on a d'Al-Qaïda comme étant finalement, ben,
les Twin Towers et le 11 septembre, qui est donc une violence qui a marqué les esprits.
Donc, comment est-ce qu'on pourrait concilier ces deux explications-là ?
Non, non. En fait, je parle pas de propagande soft, mais je parle, vraiment en termes de contenu de propagande, je parle de l'ouverture de la fenêtre d'Overton par l'État islamique en termes de violence.
Je vois.
Et évidemment, Al-Qaïda, c'est un groupe terroriste ultra-violent. Mais qu'est-ce qui s'est passé avec la propagande de l'État islamique ?
C'est que, en fait, l'État islamique s'est mis à publier des contenus,
ultra-violents. En fait, pour revenir, je pense que une des clés pour comprendre la propagande de l'État islamique, c'est de comprendre le pourquoi de cette ultra-violence.
Elle fait partie de la marque de fabrique de l'EI. Et,
en fait, elle a plusieurs objectifs, cette ultra-violence, mais en fait, elle a été pensée, elle a été théorisée par Zarqawî, qui était le fondateur du premier avatar de l'État islamique au milieu des années 2000.
Et en fait, elle a été menée dans un objectif stratégique. L'idée, à cette période-là, c'était de montrer, c'était de diffuser des images d'exaction ou d'attentat contre les populations chiites en Irak,
dans l'optique de radicaliser ces populations chiites pour qu'elles-mêmes répondent également de manière violente contre les populations sunnites, ce qui devait permettre à l'État islamique à l'époque de s'imposer comme
le groupe le plus à même de défendre ces populations sunnites.
Et donc, en fait, la diffusion de cette ultra-violence s'est réalisée dans cette optique-là, et ensuite a perduré.
Évidemment, Al-Qaïda est également un groupe très très violent, donc y a pas de groupe soft ou de groupe pas soft.
Et c'est-- on parle vraiment de contenu et de ce qu'on montre et de ce qu'on diffuse.
Pour reprendre ce que vous disiez, donc vous expliquiez que l'État islamique allait beaucoup plus dans l'émotionnel, allait cibler donc un public large dans le but de peupler donc son califat.
Donc voilà, ici, évidemment, on ne va évidemment pas
relayer ces contenus-là et montrer concrètement à quoi ça ressemblait, cette ultra-violence et ces contenus qui allaient dans le pathos et qui ciblaient donc le,
le grand public via des messages très émotionnels.
Concrètement, si vous deviez un petit peu nous décrire ce que voyait à ce moment-là le public ciblé par ces vidéos, à quoi ça ressemblait, ce type de contenu produit par l'État islamique ?
Concrètement, un exemple qui vous aurait frappé.
Ben, y a des choses qui sont très connues, hein. Je veux dire, les contenus très crus, très graphiques, très violents, c'était à la fois des
des contenus qui montraient la souffrance de la population syrienne, pour susciter justement-
Une empathie
...de l'empathie. On la montrait de façon très très crue, mais également une ultra-violence sur ce que l'État islamique faisait subir à ses ennemis.
Et je vais pas rentrer dans le détail, mais on en a beaucoup parlé dans les médias. Donc, y avait une médiatisation de ces exactions.
Et ça, à nouveau, en fait, ça s'est fait dans une optique stratégique, dans une optique pensée.
L'idée, c'était quoi ? L'idée, c'était-- il y avait plusieurs idées, en fait. C'était d'intimider les ennemis, les ennemis proches et les ennemis lointains, regardez ce qu'on est capable de faire, jusqu'où on est capable d'aller.
L'idée, c'était également d'intimider les populations qui étaient sous leur domination, quand l'État islamique était en domination territoriale.
Mais également, on a vu, et ça, c'est très intéressant, on a vu que la diffusion de cette ultra-violence avait un effet sur le recrutement.
Il y a des études qui ont montré que y a une concomitance entre la diffusion de l'ultra-violence, notamment au milieu/fin des années 2000, et l'attrait qu'exerçaient ces groupes pour les jeunes recrues.
Et on est en fait vraiment face à une sorte de fascination sordide pour ces exactions. Et je reprendrai ici les termes d'un-- de Thierry Lamotte.
Le professeur Thierry Lamotte, qui est un spécialiste de la violence, qui explique très bien que, alors que le rôle habituel du religieux, c'est de protéger des pulsions de meurtre, etc.
vraiment les sortes d'interdits fondateurs. Ici, il y a une inversion qui s'est produite, avec une sorte de rupture de ces interdits fondateurs et de ces pulsions et qui sont ici légitimés, sous couvert du fait religieux.
Et donc ça a exercé une certaine attraction vis-à-vis d'une audience qui avait déjà en elle un potentiel de violence, une appétence pour la violence et qui a pu, comment dire, l'exprimer avec une validation religieuse.
Et donc on a vu en fait que sur des comportements individuels, y a eu-- ces images violentes ont eu un effet.
Il y a eu d'abord une banalisation, hein, de cette ultra-violence. C'est-- enfin, c'est ce dont on parlait il y a quelques secondes avec la fenêtre d'Overton.
C'est-à-dire que, quand l'État islamique a commencé à diffuser ses contenus
très graphiques, des contenus d'Al-Qaïda qui, quelques années auparavant, nous semblaient extrêmement choquants, à juste titre, et finalement, en valeur relative, devenaient beaucoup moins choquants. C'est ça ?
Voilà, c'est pour ça que je parlais de second plan.
La fenêtre d'Overton.
C'est ça.
Ça devenait de facto moins choquant. Donc il y a eu ce premier effet de banalisation de cette violence
avec tout l'effet mimétique que ça peut avoir sur certains esprits, soit faibles, soit qui ont cette appétence pour la violence, hein, presque une sorte d'effet tutoriel, hein.
On va imiter le geste de ce qu'on voit à l'écran. On l'a vu, hein, certaines personnes qui sont passées à l'acte
Qui se sont repus de propagande avant de passer à l'acte, qui se sont vraiment nourris de manière compulsive de cette propagande avant de passer à l'acte.
Et cette consommation a pu avoir une incidence sur ces comportements violents.
Ça a pu fonctionner sur certains, comme vous dites, certains esprits faibles. Mais pour prendre-
Mais pas forcément. Excusez-moi, je-- pas forcément des esprits faibles. Il y a eu une étude du MI5 britannique, enfin de,
des services intérieurs britanniques en 2018, qui a montré
que en fait, quand on avait un avatar en ligne plus violent que soi-même, on risquait de s'approprier cet avatar et de finir par se glisser dans la peau de cet avatar.
C'est-à-dire qu'on expérimentait au travers de cet avatar un soi-même plus violent. Et
tout cela, et toute cette présence sur les réseaux sociaux, etc., a pu influer sur un certain nombre de comportements violents,
certaines violences débridées en ligne, qui a pu ensuite être intériorisé par un certain nombre de personnes qui ensuite sont passées à l'acte.
Oui. Donc voilà, vous parlez donc de contenus
de plus en plus violents, de plus en plus, voilà, qui tablaient donc sur le pathos, l'émotionnel, et qui ont fait, si j'entends bien ce que vous dites,
que les contenus produits par Al-Qaïda semblaient, eux, plus fades et passés.
C'est pour ça que je parlais de second plan. Donc, quels ont été alors les défis pour Al-Qaïda ?
Alors en fait, Al-Qaïda a su, au cours des années où l'État islamique a occupé le devant de la scène,
la scène politique, la scène médiatique, Al-Qaïda a su garder, à ne pas tomber dans une sorte de surenchère et à essayer de garder le temps long.
Et, en quelque sorte, à faire profil bas,
à continuer à s'implanter dans ces différentes filiales, enfin dans les différentes régions, à creuser cette implantation, à s'imbriquer dans les griefs locaux et à accentuer cette décentralisation.
Et en cela,
à davantage instrumentaliser certains conflits,
mais avoir une propagande qui s'exprimait à plus bas bruit que la propagande de l'État islamique, qui s'est attiré les foudres du contre-terrorisme, les foudres des plateformes, etc., des autorités.
Évidemment, la propagande de l'État islamique devenait la propagande numéro un à éradiquer. La propagande d'Al-Qaïda passait au second plan.
Maintenant, ces deux propagandes existent toujours et sont toujours diffusées, sont toujours diffusées en ligne.
Mh. Et je pense qu'il y a aussi eu un défi donc pour Al-Qaïda, je présume, à partir du moment où la figure donc de son leader, Ben Laden, a disparu, a été déchue.
Est-ce qu'il n'y a pas eu à ce moment-là une forme de,
de fragmentation médiatique, enfin de défi à partir du moment où — puisqu'on expliquait que pendant tout un temps, la stratégie médiatique, anciennement, bien sûr, c'était donc les fameuses VHS de Ben Laden.
À partir du moment où la figure médiatique a disparu, a été assassinée, est-ce qu'il n'y a pas eu un défi plus important alors pour Al-Qaïda ?
Alors, je dirais que la mort du leader dans les groupes djihadistes, finalement, en tout cas, là, c'est le cas pour Al-Qaïda, est régulièrement surmontée.
C'est-à-dire que, là, l'idée pour le groupe djihadiste, c'est que Ben Laden est mort en martyr. Donc vous avez une sorte de sublimation de son image qui est survalorisée, il est mort en martyr et on glorifie l'image.
Mais l'idée, c'est que le long terme ne repose pas sur les hommes. C'est vrai aussi pour l'État islamique.
Donc, à la mort de Ben Laden, Zawahiri a pris la suite du leadership d'Al-Qaïda, jusqu'à sa mort très récente.
D'ailleurs, on ne sait toujours pas qui va remplacer Zawahiri. Mais les publications ont continué à exister et la propagande a continué à exister.
Et la figure de Ben Laden est toujours omniprésente dans la propagande, qu'il soit vivant ou mort. Et quand il est,
quand il est mort, c'est vraiment la figure de martyr qui a pris la place de la figure du leader.
Donc, si vous voulez, même si ça a un impact symbolique, au moment où Ben Laden est mort, il était tellement isolé du reste que l'impact opérationnel a été relativement faible sur le groupe.
D'accord. Pour revenir à ce qu'on disait juste avant, sur la fenêtre d'Overton, sur le,
l'ultra-violence, le côté, le pathos, le fait de capitaliser finalement sur une souffrance, qui est bien là donc pour certaines personnes en Occident.
Je pense notamment qu'il y a eu une capitalisation de l'État islamique sur certaines fractures en Occident, par exemple pendant le COVID, par exemple
aux États-Unis, lors de la mort de George Floyd et de — voilà, le fait que les injustices au niveau racial étaient particulièrement évidentes aux États-Unis à ce moment-là.
Est-ce que c'est juste ? Et voilà, comment est-ce que ça a pu, par exemple, apparaître ce genre de capitalisation ?
Alors, ce qu'il faut réaliser avec la propagande de ces groupes, c'est qu'elle repose sur plusieurs thématiques phares, mais elle est suffisamment malléable pour se greffer à des faits d'actualité.
Mh.
Et donc, ce qui est marquant, si vous voulez, avec la propagande de ces groupes, c'est qu'elle repose sur un certain nombre de leitmotivs, de thématiques qui ressortent régulièrement.
Et la propagande, elle est suffisamment plastique pour se greffer à des faits marquants d'actualité.
Et donc ça a été vrai pour le COVID, ça a été vrai pour les manifestations de Black Lives Matter au moment de la mort de George Floyd.
C'est vrai également pour d'autres types de faits. Pour le COVID, qu'est-ce qui s'est passé ?
Al-Qaïda et l'État islamique étaient d'accord sur le fait que le COVID, c'était en fait une punition divine, une punition divine parce qu'un certain nombre de comportements religieux n'avaient pas été respectés, etc.
Là où les groupes divergeaient, c'était sur la manière dont il fallait tirer son épingle du jeu. L'État islamique, lui,
disait qu'il fallait, disons, tirer son épingle du jeu, de la désorganisation des pays occidentaux, du chaos qui avait régné dans les pays occidentaux, alors qu'Al-Qaïda, lui, et ça, c'est
très intéressant parce qu'Al-Qaïda a une approche qui est
beaucoup plus politique que l'État islamique, a
cherché à davantage recruter, à davantage convaincre pendant cette période-là et, comment dire,
accuser les gouvernements, notamment les gouvernements occidentaux, de dépenser trop d'argent dans leur guerre contre les pays musulmans plutôt que d'en dépenser pour lutter contre le COVID.
Et donc à chaque fois, il y a cette idée chez Al-Qaïda d'essayer de
désolidariser certaines populations en Occident par rapport au gouvernement et d'avoir une approche plus politique, de s'immiscer en fait dans la politique intérieure des pays occidentaux
pour essayer de polariser.
Il s'est passé la même chose avec les événements autour de la mort de George Floyd,
où Al-Qaïda a souligné les discriminations qui sont subies par les personnes noires aux États-Unis pour essayer d'exacerber les dissensions,
au sein de la société américaine et se positionner comme le défenseur des faibles.
Tout ça dans une optique de sensibilisation à sa cause, toujours dans cette optique de conquête des cœurs et des esprits.
Mais ce qui est parfaitement malhonnête puisque donc vous-
Ce qui est parfaitement malhonnête.
Vous nous expliquiez que ces mêmes groupes ont une idéologie parfaitement antisémite de l'autre côté. Donc c'est parfaitement contradictoire.
Tout à fait. Tout à fait, c'est parfaitement contradictoire, mais l'idée, c'est d'avoir une approche, toujours cette approche de conquête des cœurs et des esprits.
Bien sûr, bien sûr.
Et de se positionner comme l'instigateur, comme celui qui va montrer les failles et les dissensions au sein
des pays ennemis, des nations ennemies et toujours montrer du doigt les gouvernements et essayer de recruter au sein d'un vivier de population qui est,
qui subit le plus de souffrance, de grief, etc., etc.
Oui. Alors, on a donc beaucoup parlé des différentes formes que pouvaient prendre les stratégies médiatiques de ces différents groupes djihadistes.
Quelle doit être la réponse de l'Occident à ces propagandes ? Est-ce qu'on doit tabler donc plutôt sur une modération plus ciblée, de supprimer le plus rapidement possible ces contenus ?
Est-ce qu'il faut produire un contre-discours ? Quelle doit être la réponse de l'Occident ?
Alors, l'Occident, enfin en tout cas, les États hostiles aux groupes djihadistes ont un certain nombre de réponses.
En fait, il y a des réponses multiples. Mais ces réponses multiples s'articulent autour de deux piliers, le pilier du répressif et le pilier du préventif.
On a des réponses à plusieurs niveaux. On a des réponses au niveau cinétique et militaire, on a des réponses au niveau cyber, on a des réponses au niveau numérique et on a des réponses en termes de contre-discours.
Alors, si on a encore quelques minutes, je peux développer ces différents éléments parce que c'est assez intéressant.
La diminution de la production des contenus de l'État islamique, depuis 2016, on va dire, est largement due au fait que l'État islamique a moins de ressources à consacrer à ce champ de combat-là.
Pourquoi ? Parce qu'il n'est plus en domination territoriale. Il est passé à un stade insurrectionnel. Il a moins de ressources à attribuer à cela.
Et ça, c'est dû aux actions militaires de la coalition.
Mh.
C'est dû aux actions militaires globales, mais c'est dû également à des actions militaires ciblées. Et il y a un certain nombre de responsables des médias de l'État islamique qui ont été tués, visés par des drones
tout au long de cette période-là, ce qui contribue évidemment à la désorganisation
de ces productions médiatiques.
Donc ça, c'est une première réponse sur le terrain cinétique et militaire. Vous avez également une réponse au niveau cyber.
Alors au niveau cyber, il y a eu plusieurs éléments, mais je crois qu'on peut citer un
des éléments phares qui a été l'opération Glowing Symphony,
qui a été menée en deux mille quinze de mémoire par la Joint Task Force, qui s'appelait la Joint Task Force AS, américaine,
qui a consisté, cette opération a consisté à détourner, à pirater des comptes réseaux sociaux de l'État islamique et à supprimer, neutraliser des sites et des serveurs qui appartenaient au groupe.
Donc au départ, c'était vraiment une opération presque d'observation et c'est devenu une opération offensive.
Et j'encourage d'ailleurs vos auditeurs à aller écouter des podcasts s'ils s'intéressent à cela sur l'opération Glowing Symphony, parce que c'est vraiment,
extrêmement intéressant et fascinant d'entendre les personnes qui ont participé à cette opération dire que voilà, ils rentraient dans des réseaux vraiment comme s'ils entraient dans des,
dans des chambres fortes avec une sorte d'adrénaline et de suspense, comme s'ils étaient vraiment sur le terrain.
Et c'est disponible alors en anglais, en français ou... ?
C'est disponible en anglais, en podcast.
D'accord. Ok, ben, je mettrai alors le lien en description. Ça a l'air effectivement-
C'est extrêmement intéressant.
Alléchant. On dirait un film, on dirait un film hollywoodien, la façon dont vous en parlez.
Tout à fait. Tout à fait. Et donc voilà, il y a eu des réponses au niveau cyber offensif hein, on va dire cyber offensif.
Oui donc là, on parle vraiment de cybersécurité quoi, d'attaque-
Là, on parle de cyber offensif pour aller vraiment détruire des comptes, des serveurs, etc. Et c'est une opération qui a duré — qui a été longue hein, qui a duré plusieurs mois.
Ils sont restés dans leurs systèmes, dans leurs serveurs, etc. Et cette opération a contribué à l'arrêt d'un certain nombre de publications de l'État islamique.
Donc c'est vraiment quelque chose de — ça a été un levier dans la lutte contre-
Ok, ok, ok. C'est bien noté.
Donc c'est au niveau cyber, mais vous avez également au niveau purement numérique, avec l'action à la fois des autorités et l'action des plateformes.
Vous avez des suppressions de comptes, des suppressions de sites, des suppressions de groupes, de la part des plateformes.
Les plateformes, en fait, depuis les attentats de Paris de janvier et novembre deux mille quinze, vous avez les grandes plateformes qui se sont organisées,
qui ont créé le GIFCT, c'est le Global Internet Forum to Counter Terrorism,
en mettant au commun une sorte de base de données de contenus extrémistes, auxquels est attribué — enfin à chaque contenu est attribué une empreinte numérique unique.
Et cette base de données est partagée entre plusieurs plateformes. Et lorsqu'un contenu est repéré sur une plateforme, il est ajouté à cette base et en théorie, cela empêche ce contenu d'émerger sur d'autres plateformes.
Donc il y a un certain nombre de techniques-
D'outils qui ont été mis en place.
D'outils, de software qui ont été mis en place pour empêcher l'émergence de ces contenus sur ces autres plateformes.
Ensuite, on a une manière de les contourner hein, de ces,
ces outils. Et c'est d'ailleurs tout le jeu du chat et de la souris auquel joue cette propagande de l'État islamique et de ce type de groupes, donc d'échapper en masquant les logos, etc., etc.
On en viendra peut-être — si on a plus de temps. Mais voilà, il y a cette action des plateformes. Il y a également une action, évidemment, des autorités au niveau national, au niveau européen, etc.
avec des déréférencements de sites, avec des retraits de contenus, etc. Là, il y a une loi au niveau européen, le Digital Service Act, qui a acté justement la nécessité de supprimer ces contenus en une heure.
Voilà, il y a un certain nombre de mesures qui sont prises au niveau des autorités, au niveau des plateformes, des actions qui sont menées également au niveau de la société civile hein, avec des,
des collectifs de vigilants type Katiba des Narvalos.
Il y a un collectif qui agit sur Internet et qui signale et qui tente de supprimer des contenus et des comptes, des pages, etc.
qui sont liés à l'État islamique. Donc voilà, il y a eu une sorte de mise en commun d'un certain nombre d'entités pour lutter contre cette propagande au niveau réactif.
Ensuite, au niveau préventif, effectivement, vous citez le contre-discours. Donc il y a eu des initiatives hein, de contre-discours.
Il y a eu des initiatives diverses, officielles, sociétales, privées. C'est un petit peu difficile pour l'instant d'avoir du recul sur ces campagnes hein.
Il y a relativement peu d'analyses, relativement-
Mais qu'est-ce qui a pu être fait, par exemple, au niveau de, voilà, de la France, de la République ?
Qu'est-ce que la France a pu produire comme contre-discours ? Est-ce que-
Le premier contre-discours qui a été produit par la France, c'était dans le cadre de Stop Jihadisme. Ça, c'est sorti en deux mille quinze après les attentats de janvier, et c'était une petite vidéo,
qui montrait ce que l'État islamique promettait et ce qui se réalisait effectivement là-bas.
Ça, c'était la toute première campagne. Ils vous annoncent que vous allez-
Vous dites ça de manière très très abstraite. Oui, voilà, concrètement, qu'est-ce que ça-
Ils vous annoncent, il y avait une partie en couleur, ils vous annoncent que vous allez vivre une grande aventure au pays du Levant, etc.
Et ensuite ça passe en noir et blanc avec la réalité que vous allez vivre, c'est que vous allez mourir seul loin de chez vous.
Donc il y a,
ben plusieurs types de messages dans ce sens-là. Cette campagne a eu un succès mitigé parce que, notamment parce qu'elle était estampillée République française et que donc c'était vraiment une campagne très, très, très marquée
et que donc les personnes qui sont déjà radicalisées ont évidemment du mal à adhérer à un message étatique. Donc voilà,
une campagne qui a eu un effet mitigé, mais qui a eu comme mérite d'avoir un effet informationnel sur les familles et une sorte de prise de conscience d'un certain nombre de familles sur attention,
je vais davantage surveiller mes enfants, je vais davantage surveiller mon frère, ma sœur, etc.
savoir ce qu'ils font sur Internet. Et voilà, ça a eu cette vertu-là. Ensuite, maintenant, il existe également des campagnes qui sont financées par l'État, qui sont réalisées par des associations.
Mais on se heurte à des problématiques de volume, on se heurte à des problématiques de procédure et le fait de pénétrer la bulle des écosystèmes radicaux.
C'est-à-dire que quand il y a une vidéo de contre-discours, des messages de contre-discours, c'est toujours très difficile de pénétrer
ces groupes qui sont assez fermés parce que ces groupes-là ne tolèrent pas la remise en question, la remise en cause et donc c'est compliqué d'y rester et de s'y insérer quoi.
Oui oui, c'est ça. Mais peut-être qu'alors ces contre-discours ciblent plutôt les potentielles cibles, les gens qui ne sont pas encore radicalisés.
Tout à fait. Tout à fait. Alors l'idée évidemment, puis contre-discours,
maintenant, on a un peu changé de terme, maintenant, on dit plutôt discours alternatif et ça s'adresse effectivement, comme vous le dites, à des personnes qui sont peut-être
vulnérables, mais pas encore radicalisées.
Et l'idée qui, en tout cas à titre personnel, doit sans doute le mieux fonctionner, c'est de faire appel à des discours plus positifs.
C'est-à-dire que plutôt que de faire appel à des mises en garde, plutôt de faire appel à
des éléments qui stimulent, qui mettent en lumière des discours d'adhésion à des valeurs communes, un discours d'adhésion à des réussites, en fait, à des rôles modèles, des gens qui auraient réussi,
pour que justement ne puisse pas se développer ce biais de victimisation
sur lequel joue la propagande extrémiste de manière très régulière.
L'idée, c'est de dire : vous n'allez pas y arriver, mais avec nous, vous allez pouvoir vivre quelque chose de différent, réussir dans la vie, etc.
Donc là, l'idée d'un discours alternatif positif, ce serait de montrer justement des rôles modèles qui viendraient un peu couper l'herbe sous le pied de ce type de discours de victimisation.
Ok donc ça, c'est pour
le contre-discours, les essais qui ont été faits à ce niveau-là.
L'an dernier, j'ai pu tomber sur un article de Politico qui expliquait que l'État islamique avait fait un post Facebook pour annoncer fièrement le meurtre de
treize soldats irakiens et que pour contourner la modération dont on parlait il y a un instant, les réponses, voilà, au niveau des plateformes,
pour contourner la modération, ils avaient accompagné le post d'une grande photo de Mark Zuckerberg.
Donc qu'est-ce que les djihadistes mettent en place pour, voilà, outre cet exemple qui est un petit peu amusant et consternant à la fois, qu'est-ce que les djihadistes peuvent mettre en place pour contourner la censure ?
Ah oui, c'est un exemple intéressant, mais enfin, c'est un exemple qui est très emblématique, donc c'est un très bon exemple.
Ce qu'on se disait tout à l'heure, en début de l'heure, c'était que dès le milieu des années 2000, les djihadistes ont mis en place une sorte de guérilla en ligne, de guerre d'attrition en ligne.
Et l'idée pour eux, c'est de conserver leur empreinte numérique coûte que coûte sur les grandes plateformes, même si leurs contenus sont
éphémères, même s'ils sont supprimés, parce que c'est là qu'ils peuvent parler de leurs faits d'armes, c'est là qu'ils peuvent magnifier leurs actions, c'est là qu'ils peuvent s'adresser au plus grand nombre, etc.
Donc l'idée pour eux, c'est vraiment de garder cette présence sur les grands réseaux sociaux. Et en cela, ils utilisent tout un tas de tactiques qu'en fait, on peut presque comparer à des tactiques de guérilla.
Ils utilisent, ben par exemple, votre exemple de Mark Zuckerberg, c'est à la fois de la dissimulation et de la ruse, c'est-à-dire qu'on se fait passer pour ce qu'on n'est pas.
En gros, on met une photo de Mark Zuckerberg qui ne va pas du tout être repérée par l'intelligence artificielle, par le soft qui va être mis en place par Facebook,
plutôt que de mettre une photo de l'État islamique avec le logo de l'État islamique.
Vous mettez une photo qui passe de manière complètement invisible.
Passe-partout quoi, ouais ouais.
Qui passe partout. Et voilà. Et tout ça, c'est quoi ? C'est de la ruse et de la dissimulation. Exactement comme ce qu'il peut y avoir sur le terrain.
Donc, vous avez, voilà, du foutage de gueule, de la fugacité, par exemple, avec des contenus comme des stories qui sont beaucoup moins repérés par la modération.
Les stories qui sont donc des contenus éphémères qui restent là, qui restent dispo pour vingt-quatre heures sur Instagram, sur Facebook, voilà.
Exactement. Vous avez des fondations médiatiques qui sont a priori neutres, en tout cas qui affichent un positionnement neutre, mais qui ne publient que des nouvelles du groupe djihadiste que, in fine, ils soutiennent.
Mmh-mmh.
Etc, etc. Vous avez tout un... Ça, on pourrait faire une heure sur ce type de tactique, mais, pour moi, c'est vraiment de la guérilla, et une forme de guerre d'attrition.
Il y a des tactiques de harcèlement également. Lors d'une vidéo qui est sortie il y a quelques années, qui s'appelle Inside the Caliphate 8, cette doctrine de harcèlement est très bien expliquée.
Ils disent : « Si vous supprimez un compte, on va en créer trois. Si vous en supprimez trente, on va en créer trente.
» Donc vraiment, vraiment, il y a cette espèce de volonté de résilience, de harcèlement,
Mmh-mmh.
de débordement de l'adversaire, comme une sorte de guérilla. On peut également pousser la métaphore par rapport
aux actions sur le terrain
avec parfois des contenus ou des comptes dont les djihadistes savent qu'ils ne vont pas rester longtemps en ligne parce qu'ils vont être repérés par les plateformes et qu'ils nomment eux-mêmes des comptes inghimasi.
Alors un inghimasi sur le terrain, c'est un combattant qui va percer les lignes ennemies, qui va essayer de faire le plus de victimes possible en essayant de s'en sortir.
Eh bien là, on a certains comptes qui réussissent à
percer, en quelque sorte, à pénétrer les plateformes malgré l'intervention, malgré la censure des plateformes, rester le plus longtemps en ligne pour diffuser des contenus avant de se faire supprimer, mais en ayant quand même
parlé de différents faits d'armes, recruté, contacté des personnes, etc.
Et donc il y a ce jeu, voilà, ce que vous disiez tout à l'heure, c'est le jeu du chat et de la souris quoi, de
on met en place différentes techniques pour
rester en place, les stories comme vous disiez, la résilience, ces formes de harcèlement, de non non, mais vous essayez de nous supprimer, mais
on revient, on crée, vous supprimez trois comptes, on revient avec trente, avec trois cents, voilà.
J'aimerais partir sur un sujet un petit peu différent. Dans un article de GNET, donc qui est le Global Network on Extremism and Technology,
vous vous penchiez sur le cas du meurtre de Samuel Paty, dont on a beaucoup parlé
ces dernières années, et vous utilisiez l'analogie de l'offre et la demande.
Est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer, est-ce qu'on aurait pu observer des phénomènes d'offre et de demande et d'empêcher l'attaque ?
De quoi s'agit-il exactement ?
Alors, dans le cas de Samuel Paty, c'était particulier. D'ailleurs, on a commémoré hier les deux ans de son assassinat.
C'était le seize octobre deux mille vingt. Effectivement, ça a été un phénomène qui était très spécifique, dont la dynamique numérique a été très spécifique.
C'est-à-dire qu'à l'origine, il s'agissait de rester... On aurait pu régler cette histoire en restant au sein de son établissement.
Mmh-mmh.
En discutant les yeux dans les yeux. Mais il se trouve que
l'accusation qui a été proférée contre Samuel Paty est sortie sur les réseaux sociaux et que ces réseaux sociaux ont servi en quelque sorte de tribunal populaire et de mise en accusation de Samuel Paty.
À côté de ça, vous aviez une personne, son assassin, qui depuis plusieurs semaines, depuis plusieurs mois, était en recherche de cibles.
Et donc quand on parle de rencontre, d'une offre de cible et d'une demande de cible,
Mmh.
je parlais justement de
cette trajectoire et de la manière dont elles vont s'intersecter. C'est-à-dire que d'une part,
vous avez une sorte de tribunal populaire qui va mettre en avant le nom de Samuel Paty, de son établissement sur les réseaux sociaux et de l'autre quelqu'un qui cherche une victime.
Et donc il va y avoir une rencontre en fait entre ces deux phénomènes et c'est le croisement de ces deux phénomènes qui a engendré le drame.
D'accord. Et donc en fait, ce que vous expliquez dans l'article, c'est que le tueur,
on pouvait déjà observer sur, je pense que c'était son compte Twitter, vraiment l'expression, voilà, de comme vous disiez, une demande de « je cherche une victime » quelque part, on pouvait le déceler finalement, si on,
si vraiment, on prenait le temps d'observer ce tweet,
est-ce qu'on aurait pu anticiper ?
C'est très compliqué de répondre à cette question. C'est très compliqué parce qu'on est face à une volumétrie qui est impressionnante de contenus
Bien sûr.
radicaux, de contenus haineux, de contenus violents. Et en fait, c'est extrêmement compliqué de percevoir ce qui, dans des posts radicaux, va susciter un passage à l'acte.
Qu'est-ce qui peut être prémonitoire d'un passage à l'acte, d'une bascule d'une haine en ligne vers un comportement violent dans la vie réelle ?
Et dans le cas de Samuel Paty, je pense que c'était vraiment très compliqué de percevoir ça, d'autant plus que son assassin passait en message privé, etc etc.
Il y a évidemment un certain nombre de facteurs qui peuvent, enfin, il y a un certain nombre de faisceaux de facteurs qui créent un faisceau d'indices et qui auraient pu alerter.
Mais encore une fois, c'est très facile de refaire l'histoire
Bien sûr.
quand l'histoire est déjà faite et quand on connaît la fin et de relire les événements ex post,
Oui.
quelques semaines après.
Et de se dire que finalement, ça aurait été facile de l'empêcher.
Et que finalement, ça aurait été facile. Je crois que quand les choses se déroulent sous nos yeux, c'est beaucoup plus compliqué
Bien sûr
...parce qu'on a tendance à voir dans le flou et que c'est très difficile de déceler ce qui est vraiment problématique ou ce qui l'est un petit peu moins.
Bien sûr. Alors Laurence Bindner, on va bientôt devoir se quitter. Une dernière question que je voulais aborder avec vous, c'est finalement la question de la méthodologie finalement.
Quelles sont les méthodes que vous employez pour analyser les contenus djihadistes dont on a parlé, voilà, pendant une heure ensemble ?
Et en fait, l'idée pour tout type de contenu extrémiste, c'est d'être sur les bonnes plateformes. Finalement, quand on connaît les plateformes d'émergence de ces contenus, c'est très facile de les trouver.
Ensuite, ce qui est intéressant, c'est d'analyser les contenus eux-mêmes,
d'analyser en fait les messages, d'analyser les supports de ces messages, d'analyser les cibles auxquelles sont adressés ces messages.
Est-ce que c'est plutôt des contenus qui sont adressés à des jeunes ? Est-ce que c'est plutôt des contenus qui sont adressés à des femmes ?
Est-ce que c'est plutôt des contenus qui sont adressés... À quel type de personnes sont adressés ces contenus ? Donc d'adresser une sorte de segmentation dans les audiences cibles, susceptibles
de s'approprier ces contenus et
d'être radicalisées, en fait, par ces contenus.
Mh.
Et donc l'idée, c'est à la fois une analyse sur la forme du contenu et sur le fond du contenu. Qu'est-ce que ce contenu nous dit ?
Comment est-ce qu'il le dit ? Comment c'est exprimé ? Avec quel champ lexical c'est exprimé ?
Avec quel type de visuel ça s'est exprimé ? Est-ce que c'est plutôt un visuel violent ? Est-ce que c'est plutôt un visuel didactique ?
Est-ce que c'est plutôt un visuel destiné à des enfants, par exemple ? Et cetera, et cetera. Et donc c'est comme ça que l'analyse de ces contenus peut être menée pour vraiment
comprendre et percevoir ce que ces groupes-là ou ce que ces individus-là nous disent.
Mh. Et à titre personnel, donc là aujourd'hui, on, voilà, on est dans un exercice journalistique, un exercice de presse.
Est-ce que parler de toutes ces questions publiquement, est-ce que c'est quelque chose avec lequel vous devez être prudent ?
Est-ce que c'est quelque chose
Alors nous
...qui représente finalement une forme de danger pour vous ?
Nous, nous on est, enfin voilà, je suis analyste.
Ouais
...j'analyse essentiellement la rhétorique et c'est pour ça que j'en parle publiquement avec vous ou avec d'autres.
Mh.
Je ne suis pas les services de renseignement, et
C'est ça
...voilà, et c'est en termes intellectuels, en termes analytiques que je publie sur ce type de contenu et sur cette dynamique de propagande.
Ouais, donc vous êtes sereine, finalement. Y a pas de danger dans...
Tout à fait. Oui.
Tout à fait. Ok, très bien. Alors, on va bientôt se quitter comme je le disais. Est-ce que vous souhaitez partager un dernier mot avant qu'on se quitte ?
Non, écoutez, je pense qu'on a fait le tour de pas mal de questions. C'était... vos questions étaient très, très pertinentes, elles rentraient au cœur de cette expertise.
Donc c'était
Formidable
...très bien. Et la durée du podcast laisse effectivement tout le loisir de développer une pensée en profondeur et de rentrer un peu dans les détails, ce qui
Mh
...ce qui est relativement peu fréquent.
En effet. Mais j'étais ravi de partager ces Septante Minutes Avec Vous, Laurence Bindner. Merci beaucoup.
Merci Guillaume Hachez.
Et on se retrouve alors dans deux semaines pour un nouvel épisode. Merci beaucoup. Au revoir.
Au revoir.
C'est déjà tout pour cet épisode. Comme promis, j'ai mis en description le lien vers le podcast qui raconte l'opération Glowing Symphony.
Toutes mes excuses, je sais que j'ai sorti cet épisode avec une semaine de retard. Le planning des prochaines sorties est encore un petit peu flou.
Si les planètes s'alignent, normalement, mon but est de sortir l'épisode 66 dans une semaine. Je vous dis à très bientôt.
Gros bisous. Au revoir.